one of the claims made by Prince Harry
in his book is that he killed 25 Taliban
fighters while he served in Afghanistan
but also claimed that he saw them not as
people but as chess pieces instead
well joining me now to discuss this
further is retired British Army Officer
Colonel Richard Kemp who commanded the
British forces in Afghanistan in 2003.
thanks so much for talking to us at
Colonel Kemp so in Prince Harry's Memoir
he talks about his time in Afghanistan
and says that he killed 25 Taliban
fighters as former commander of British
forces in Afghanistan how do you feel
about those comments
I think they're probably ill charge
partly for two reasons really one is uh
his suggestion that he killed 25 will
have re-re incited I think those people
who wish him harm as a result of his
military service that was 10 years ago
now and the memories might have faded
well now they've been resurrected and
there will be people out there who maybe
support the Taliban uh support their
agenda who who will now be motivated I
think to to kill Harry well let's hope
they don't succeed and I'm sure he's got
pretty good security but that's one
problem the other problem I found with
his comments was that he characterized
the British army basically as having
trained him and other soldiers to see
his enemy as less than human just as
chess pieces on the board to be swiped
off which is not the case it's the
opposite of the case
um the British army is very careful to
ensure that its soldiers are trained to
respect their enemy particularly if
they're if they're uh if they're killed
and they their bodies need to be treated
with respect and if they're wounded then
they have to be given medical treatment
and if they are taken prisoner they have
to be treated according to Junior
conventions so it's not the way he
describes it I think that's a very bad
judgment
so you suggest there could be an
increased security threat against a
Prince Harry himself could that extend
to any other serviceman who served in
Afghanistan do you think
yeah I think it could do because I I
wouldn't overemphasize this point
because of course those people who want
to kill British soldiers or former
soldiers they know that the British army
killed many more than 25 but it brings
it into kind of a Sharp focus and
particularly his comments about about
how they don't regard you know their
enemy Fighters as being human beings
even so I think it will this world
inside some people to to maybe attempt
to attack against British soldiers
anywhere in the world or former British
soldiers I like I said I wouldn't
overplay that aspect but I think the
impact on his own personal security is
greater but I don't think we can ignore
that
is it unusual for a member of the
British forces to talk openly about how
many people they've killed in war
I think sometimes they will do so uh
privately probably you know with their
own comrades
um and that's that's not uncommon it's
it is not very common particularly for
people to give exact numbers of this of
the enemy they had killed obviously in
in most cases soldiers on the ground
don't know how many people have killed
because a lot of these engagements take
place at long range Harry's in a
different position with the technology
available to him and of course there
have been other other former soldiers
who have written books about their
experience in Afghanistan which they've
said who they've killed but but not with
the kind of a profile that Harry has and
I think it's you know it's not it's not
there's nothing illegal about it it
doesn't go against any military
regulations or anything but I think it's
probably this particular uh Revelation I
don't think is in very good taste
do you think that these comments
undermine the positive work that Prince
Harry did while he was in the army
yeah Prince Harry was a very courageous
Soldier he did two operational tours in
Northern in Afghanistan
um he didn't have to serve in
Afghanistan in fact he had to fight
government policy that tried to prevent
him from going because of the threat to
the third in line to the throne as he
was then
um so he had a very good reputation
because of that he was highly regarded
and that reputation was enhanced by his
championing of wounded Veterans for
example in the Invictus games but I
think some veterans will that his his
achievements and his reputation won't be
destroyed but I think this will tarnish
it to some extent in the eyes of some
veterans and as I say but not so much
the number he killed but particularly
his characterization of the British army
as being an organization that treats
their enemy as as sub-human
as a member of the royal family he was
always going to be a very high profile
member of the British forces wasn't he
would he have had special advice from
the military on how to handle that
yeah I think so I think he he
undoubtedly would have done I don't know
for sure but I I'd be surprised if he
hadn't
um and you know particularly as I I
don't know but but normally if you're
going to publish a book that discusses
military operations you usually have to
get approval from excuse me approval
from the ministry of Defense to publish
it to ensure that nothing that's secret
is revealed and whether he did that in
this case or not I don't know but if he
did then I suspect it it passed the mod
censorship procedures uh because I don't
think anything that I've seen that he
said in the book is um is is damaging I
think what this seems to me the comments
he's made I think look to me kind of
their their fairly provocative
deliberately I think
um no doubt written by a Ghostwriter to
to get these books selling
um and that's you know that's a pretty
standard stuff when you're writing A
Memoir of this sort but I think he's
should have had the judgment to to
change the words of those that ghost
writing
on Sky News now having to comment on it
um not not particularly surprised I
think we um most of us saw this coming
in the vast number of kind of previews
we've had of of the fact that he's doing
documentaries and writing Memoirs Etc so
it doesn't overly surprise me but but I
think I'm somewhat disappointed because
I do think as I said that this has
tarnished his own reputation and it also
has damaged uh if people believe it and
many will believe it it has damaged the
reputation of the British army unjustly
because the the characterization that he
makes in this book is simply not true
it's it's it's in fact the opposite of
the truth
well Colonel Richard Kemp we really
appreciate your time this morning thanks
so much for your time and your response
to Prince Harry Harry's and Memoir
Revelations we appreciate it thank you